leviticus 19 verse 28
was more of a chill suggestion making
tattoos
completely acceptable for christians
today
acceptable is going to be doing a lot of
work here
so leviticus 1928 says no tattoos
well yeah now i can't help but notice
got a little ink there that's just
that's henna that's fake i do that i
redo that every morning before i come
out
yeah the hindu artist or more likely
some like lib woman artist doing henna
tattoos
she must be very confused every morning
when you say i need the chiro on my arm
yeah well and
see the again the question is not framed
exactly correctly because my well i
don't want to give my answer until
you've guessed
okay so the so the question is
acceptable
is it are we talking about chill
suggestion yeah
is it unfair framing to begin with
yeah as far as i know god particularly
in the old testament does not generally
make
chill suggestions right neither chill
nor suggestion he would
apply to the old testament at any point
so
but the question is today do do those
specific laws still hold today
uh right and i i'm confident that you
would say
no that they don't hold
yes i suppose okay now yes
on the on the i think the substantive
read of the question
yes however the word acceptable right
it is it is my opinion that the only
people
who should have tattoos are
convicts and sailors
not body shame me first how dare you
it's you i will say you've got a kind of
burly demeanor you yeah you can pull and
it's a it's a
strange tattoo because it's it's an
ancient christian symbol
like it's oh is that what it is i don't
know if you know the uh i thought it was
japanese for water
i was going for i was going for rx like
prescription and i forgot that
you got to go back just a big fan of uh
yes okay so
we both got that right so i guess we
should drink
are those the rules by the way i know i
totally respect
um the view of uh hating tattoos yeah
and i should be a guy who hates them so
it's very confusing for people yes
like um but in terms of the uh
the old testament argument i find it
absurd clearly those are not
those are ceremonial jewish laws that
don't and there is a difference between
moral laws ceremonial laws this right
this is
sometimes people get tripped up on this
but there are and especially tattoos
in that context would have been pagan
symbolism
right but also if you get the little
like the japanese from water you know
like the 20 year old white girls do
that that is immoral that is a demonable
offense i will agree with you
yes okay
you